the White House is denying a new report
that President Trump had an extramarital
affair before he launched his political
career a story in The New Yorker says
former Playboy model Karen McDougal had
the affair with Donald Trump for about
nine months
McDougald says it started when she met
mr. Trump in 2006 at the Playboy Mansion
following a taping of his reality show
The Apprentice CBS News White House
reporter Jackie Alemany is traveling
with the president in Florida Jackie
good morning good morning the timing of
the alleged affair puts it less than two
years into Donald Trump's marriage with
Melania Trump the article also raises
questions about whether or not another
publication was trying to bury McDougald
story
we spoke with Ronan Farrow who broke the
story Karen McDougal in this written
document stresses that her relationship
with Donald Trump was entirely
consensual but her story reveals
commonalities with story after story
that has now emerged about Donald
Trump's either consensual relationships
with women or alleged non-consensual
advances
McDougal sold the rights to her story to
the publisher of the National Enquirer
barring her from discussing the details
of her relationship with Trump the story
never ran the former Playboy model told
New Yorker reporter Ronan Farrow that
the me2 movement embolden her to come
forward with her story despite fears of
legal retaliation she acknowledges that
this is a different kind of case but it
has the commonality of powerful men
using elaborate systems to silence women
and stories those women might tell about
them and she said that she didn't want
to be silenced anymore and that she
hoped her speaking about this system
that ensnared her might encourage other
women to step forward The New Yorker
report comes days after Trump lawyer
Michael Cohen admitted to paying off
stormy Daniels an adult film star who
also once claimed to have had an affair
with Trump in 2006 the payment has
raised questions with a Federal Election
Commission as it could be in violation
of campaign finance laws a White House
official refused to go on the record but
called MacDougall's story quote fake
news we asked White House press
secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders last
year if all of trumps accusers were
lying her answer was yes
Anthony Jacky Alemany traveling with the
president in Florida Thanks